We've really learned a lot.
Surely, we'll be able to answer a simple question, right?
For example, if Galileo drops a ball off the leaning tower, how far does it fall in 2 seconds?
Can we answer that? Well, we want to know distance.
I'm thinking we going to use our relationship with x, and it's somehow proportional to t².
But unfortunately, this is not enough information.
Remember how we solved this. We used ratios.
Ratios mean we need to compare two things.
If I knew how far the ball fell in 1 second or in 10 seconds or in 7 seconds, yes, I could solve this.
But I haven't even told you that.
It looks like we might be in trouble.
What we want is not a proportionality relationship.
We want an equality.
We want x equals some constant--some number that never changes--times t².
This constant is called the constant of proportionality.
Before I just tell you what the constant is
let's learn about an amazing physical tool called dimensional analysis
where "dimensional" refers to the dimensions or units of a number,
because right now we know nothing about this constant.
It could have units of length. It could have units of time.
It could have units of time squared over length cubed. We just don't know.
Let's use dimensional analysis to figure out what the units of this constant should be.
We do dimensional analysis by converting everything into units of length, time, and mass,
combination of these. Let me show you what I mean.
Let's look at this equation x equals something times time squared.
Just keep track of the units.
Well, x is a unit of length. It's a unit of distance.
On the left hand side I'll write length.
That equals some unknown here multiplied by something with units of time squared.
Solving for my question mark,
I find that the units of this unknown constant are length/time squared.
What has units of length/time squared?
Well, length/time squared could be something like meters per second squared.
That's acceleration.
This constant of proportionality that relates time and position has units of acceleration.
Pretty cool.
It turns out that this constant of proportionality is just 1/2 the acceleration
of the object that we're talking about.
For objects in free fall on earth, this acceleration happens to be equal to 10 m/s²,
which is why I've been using this as an example acceleration so much.
In fact, this number is so important we give it the abbreviation "g."
But keep in mind we only use this number when an object's in free fall.
When an object's rolling, this acceleration will be--well, you tell me.
Does an object rolling accelerate faster or slower?